well you know I always enjoy a new cycle
focused around a Trump tweet and by
enjoy I mean it makes me want to jump in
front of a cement truck but that's
that's the big topic today that Trump
trolled Donald Trump at rolled that
Greta Thune Berg on Twitter tweeting in
reaction to her winning the Person of
the Year Trump tweeted so ridiculous
Greta must work on her anger management
problem then go to a good old-fashioned
movie with a friend chill Greta chill
the media saying that this is terrible
evil etc etc etc because he's he's I
even saw there was at least one blue
checkmark on Twitter saying that he
should be impeached just based on this
tweet alone because he's attacking a
child and everything else and and some
people are pointing to some people are
pointing to man I'm boring myself
already just talking about this why am i
doing it well because there is a point I
want to make there's a point I wanna
make about the tweet and I just have to
get to it so bear with me
some people are pointing to the
perceived hypocrisy of the right and
Trump attacking a kid while at the same
time the right freaked out last week
about that dumb joke that the woman told
at the impeachment hearing about Baron
Trump and so they're saying well that's
hypocrisy okay so here's my point
with the stipulation ahead of time that
none of this matters at all my point is
that first of all uh you know I
personally continue to be not a fan of
the president trolling on Twitter I do
actually think that presidents should be
above that and should have more
important things to do i troll twitter
all the time so when I bring this up
someone always says well what are you
doing on Twitter ya know i i troll
twitter all the time i'm a petty and
immature person but importantly here I'm
not the leader of the free world so I
like to think that the president has
more important things to do than I do
though of course that will change when I
as you know ascend to my rightful throne
so I'm not a fan of it no matter what
he's saying I'm just I'm not a fan I I
don't think he's winning converts this
way I think more people are turned off
by the dumb tweeting then are turned on
by it well I hope nobody's
but you get what I'm saying III think
that he's more likely to repel people
than he is to win them III don't think
that there's anyone I don't think
there's anyone out there saying you know
I don't really like anything about Trump
but man that tweeting I love it I hate
everything about them but the tweeting I
love on the other hand there are a lot
of people saying you know I kind of like
a lot of the stuff Trump's doing but the
tweeting I just I really hate it so
there are a lot of people saying that I
don't think there's anyone on the other
side of that fence maybe there's one or
two weird weirdos on that side of the
fence but so I just politically I don't
think there's a lot of benefit to it
with that said when it comes to this
attacking a child thing and look I I
thought that the Conservatives who were
fainting over the Baron Trump joke were
being extremely dumb and embarrassing
that was just very stupid there was it
was not a big deal they weren't it
nobody was attacking Baron Trump but
there is a difference between going
after a kid who's not in politics and
going after a kid who is an activist out
on the public stage making a case making
an argument and it's important to
acknowledge this distinction because the
left's move has been recently especially
whether it's with Greta or David hog or
whoever else the move has been to
elevate these kids to the spotlight use
them as mouthpiece pieces insist that we
all take their ideas seriously and even
to point to them as an example of why
the voting age should be lowered to 16
because we that would look how competent
and insightful and intelligent these
kids are but then when we criticize then
they go well how dare you she's a child
you monster well if you're gonna do the
she's just a child thing then stop
expecting me to take her seriously and
get her off the stage you can't have it
both ways
this is why I'm firmly against getting
kids involved in politics I don't like
to see kids getting attacked whoever
they are I don't care who they are I
don't I don't like to see it but when
you
put a kid on the public stage to argue a
case to get involved in the public
debate and especially when you're using
that kid as was the case with David hog
who's not a kid anymore but when you're
using the kid as a means to argue for
taking away people's constitutional
rights well then you are putting that
person in the line for criticism
and there is a line between just
attacking somebody and criticizing them
but the problem is that the left says
you can't criticize or attack you know
attacking is wrong but criticizing is
wrong too you can't do that you just can
do this person's making an argument it
doesn't matter how old they are I'm
gonna respond to it
if and if you don't think that the child
should be involved in that kind of
dispute if you don't think that we
should be taking the argument seriously
enough to criticize it then probably
that person shouldn't be on the stage
making the argument in the first place
that's the point and so get kids off of
the stage and I don't like it when the
right does it either they do it less
often it does happen sometimes but I
don't care if it's right or left I don't
think kids should be and and also I just
a kid doesn't know anything about
politics or about the way the world
works I have never and I say this with
all due respect I was a kid once myself
but I've never heard of fourteen or
fifteen or sixteen year old say anything
that made me go oh wow I never thought
of it like that wow that's a great
insight I've never heard that and maybe
on occasion there's a really super
insightful brilliant 16 year old who
says stuff like that but for the most
part you they just don't know anything
they're still at it at a point in life
where they're learning from us they're
turning to us to tell them things which
is what kids do but it's it
and that's why we we don't we don't but
but when the left puts these these kids
on the pedestal it's not because they've
got some great insight into the issue
it's because they're using the kids as
human shields these kids are puppets
we're Girja tating the talking points
that the left assigns to them and then
the left hides behind these kids because
we're not allowed to respond because
then we'd be attacking a child I am just
not a fan of that at all okay enough of
that in fact I do have an actual
important story to discuss today before
before we before we do that a word from
policy genius if you're a homeowner you
know how tough it is to find the right
home right right find the right home
insurance coverage even if your rates
have crept up over the years the idea of
replacing your policy can seem pretty
exhausting you can seem overwhelming you
don't know where to start and it doesn't
help that December is one of the busiest
months of the year that's why policy
genius reimagine the entire process so
you can get the right coverage at the
best price here's all you need to do
first head to policy genius calm answer
a few quick questions about yourself and
your property then policy genius will
compare your policy against options from
top insurers to make sure that you're
getting the right home insurance
coverage at the best possible price
they've saved their customers an average
of six hundred and ninety dollars per
year doing just that
so think about what you could do with
that extra six hundred ninety bucks if
policy genius finds you a better rate
than what you're currently paying
they'll do all the work to get you
switch so you're saving money or saving
time you're saving the hassle there's
it's you don't stand to lose anything
you just stand to gain whether you need
home insurance for a new place or you
just want to reshape your current policy
head to policy genius.com today you can
start on your smartphones right now go
to policy genius policy genius.com
policy genius when it comes to home
insurance it's nice to get it right okay
so there was a mass shooting on Tuesday
a hate crime that left six people dead
including a police officer the two
shooters were both killed as well
probably haven't heard much about it
maybe you've heard something about it
hopefully you've heard something at
least but but not much the media is not
focused very intently on this story
let's try to figure out why first let's
look at what happened a kosher
supermarket in New Jersey in Jersey City
actually was targeted shot up three
Jewish customers that the grocery were
killed when police responded there was a
shootout and it was during the shootout
that the cop was killed and finally
thankfully the the suspects were taken
down tragic story also pretty dramatic
it's the kind of thing that you'd think
would be big headline news except
there's a problem from the media's
perspective the problem is that the
assailants are linked to be black Hebrew
Israelites the back black Hebrew
Israelites are essentially a cult an
anti-semitic racist cult and as it says
right there in the title there these are
black people so you have two black
people committing a racist anti-semitic
hate crime and they are linked to a hate
group a black supremacist hate group the
media doesn't want any part of that now
and maybe you've if I don't know how
widespread these people are I know that
you know I see him in Baltimore you seem
in DC all the time and they stand on the
street corner just shouting at people
going by shouting racist stuff to white
people walking by that's their whole
thing to make matters even worse for our
for our warriors of truth in the media
this group the black Hebrews you may
remember that name maybe it's from
seeing them on the sidewalk screaming at
you or maybe it's because they were the
people who started the altercation in DC
that was blamed infamously by the media
on the Covington Catholic kids so you
remember that of course we got that out
of context clip of Nathan Phillips
banging his drum in the face of
Cummington kids and then next thing you
know the media is going after these kids
and there's bomb threats and death
threats and everything and they're
trying to destroy their life what we
didn't see initially is that the black
Hebrew guys got the ball rolling by
screaming racist anti-gay anti white
anti Native American rhetoric at the
Covington kids and at the
of Americans and so they're the ones who
got this altercation going someone went
cut all of that out and just left it
with a short clip of the kids and the
Nate Nathan Phillips and they got blamed
for something that was the fault of the
black Hebrews and now we have the same
group linked to a terror attack a hate
crime in New Jersey and so for the media
this is this is bad news because it
doesn't it doesn't fit the narrative it
doesn't fit what they're trying to do
politically and it also brings to mind
one of the worst things they ever did
which was to completely slander these
Covington Catholic kids and try to
destroy them for something that they did
not do so that's why the media doesn't
want to emphasize this and when I say
doesn't want to emphasizes because I
brought this up yesterday online and
some people responded saying well what
do you mean I I saw the media covering
this yeah of course they're gonna cover
it that's not how fake news works yes
they're going to cover they're gonna
they're gonna they're gonna do they're
they're gonna cross the t's and dot the
i's and they're gonna do their story
about it so you can always claim and
they can always claim that hey we did we
did stories on it what are you talking
about see the point is on the emphasis
it's about that's what's so much of what
fake news is it's what do they choose to
emphasize and what do they choose to
de-emphasize and on this story yeah
they're they don't have any choice but
to talk about it obviously it's a mass
shooting it's a hate crime in New Jersey
what else are they gonna do but they're
they're not going to emphasize it the
way that they would if this was a white
supremacist group that was responsible
for this and that's that's fake news
okay though I thought this was pretty
interesting reading now from The Daily
wire it says the women's liberation
front WOL F or Wolf I suppose for short
a group that views itself as a radical
feminist organization wants to hold an
event at the Seattle Public Library but
the library is considering the
complaints of another group that calls
wolf a hate group and that group is not
some kind of Christian group or
right-wing group but the gender Justice
League which my northwest host Jason
rants terms a far left LGBT group
they're upset because Wolf's events
titled fighting the new misogyny a
feminist critique of gender identity
intends to offer quote a critical
analysis of a gender identity of gender
identity grants notes that Wolfe
dislikes instances where biological
women are disadvantaged by trans women
thus the gender Justice League so we've
got the women's liberation front versus
the the gender justice league we stop
for a minute and focus on gender justice
league quite a name for an organization
imagine an ironic Lea putting Justice
League in your in the name of your
organization thus the gender Justice
League granted the end result of a hate
group using the library as a venue to
critique the existence of a minority
group creates a hostile environment and
is unacceptable
the gender Justice League wrote we
recently find out found out that an anti
trans organization has booked an event
at the Seattle Public Library with the
express purpose of arguing to take away
legal rights for trans people
the library has put out an immediate
response to continuing to look at their
options in the situation and then the
gender justice league added a legal
threat as well and so anyway you get the
idea there they're trying to shut down
this event and so what you see here is
the the burgeoning civil war on the left
between what I guess we now would call
radical feminists and and the people who
are proponents of the gender ideology
and gender identity but think about
what's happened here we're now
it is you are you're a radical feminist
if you simply take the position that
only human beings with female
reproductive organs are in fact women
that is now a radical feminist position
to take but these are and I'm no I'm
certainly no defender of feminism by any
stretch of the imagination but these
feminists and and they they I have no
doubt that they are radical in other
areas at least if we started talking
about abortion I'm sure that they're
they're true radical nature would come
to the forefront but what they're saying
about the trans stuff is not at all
radical that's just science but also
what they realize that this group of
feminists and I think it's a relatively
small group within the larger feminism
but what what what they're doing is
they're trying to preserve and protect
the gains of feminism over the last
several decades many of those gains I'm
not a fan of and and I would like to see
them lose those gains such as the gain
the quote gain of being able to kill
children but they do realize that what's
happening with the gender identity
identity stuff gender ideology is that
all of that now is threatened because
what feminists have been doing it's it's
it's all about drawing this distinction
between men and women
it's about painting you know women as
victims
it's about this creating this tension
this competitiveness between men and
women
you know presenting women as a group
that is has to struggle against this
other group of men the patriarchy and
everything in order for any of that to
work and make sense we need to know what
women are and it needs to be the case
that only women can be women because if
men can now be women then everything
feminists have been doing is blown to
smithereens
so you've got these two groups now
destroying each other and it's it's a
it's a weird situation for someone like
myself or anybody on the right because
on one hand I think radical feminists
are what they stand for is vile and evil
destructive these are often just I don't
think there's any word for it but
bloodthirsty people when you look at
their approach to their their utter
disregard for the unborn and their
support for killing babies at any stage
of development for any reason it's vile
violent bloodthirsty brutal barbaric so
on one hand there's that on the other
hand when it comes to the gender stuff
they're absolutely right so I don't know
I don't know who to root for I guess
it's one of those you just root for both
sides to lose I suppose all right so I'm
late to this but I was speaking of
feminism I was reminded about it
yesterday when Emily's an audio
colleague of mine at the Daily wire
tweeted about it
it's the woke version the woke version
of baby it's cold outside
John Legend didn't Kelly Clarkson
recorded a progressive version of the
song because they were concerned that
the original is offensive in the me2 era
so you're familiar probably with the
criticism of the original baby it's cold
outside people say that it sounds like
the man is trying to violate the woman's
consent all of that when when really in
reality it's just a song about a man and
woman flirting the woman is playing
hard-to-get she's clearly dropping hints
that she wants to stay in the man's
trying to convince her so it's this
back-and-forth flirtatious flirtatious
thing that's the song these days though
it's it's problematic so they they did
this new version and I heard it about a
month ago and I thought it was hilarious
really I laughed hysterically and then I
forgot about it but it really is very
funny unintentionally so I don't know if
you've heard it yet but I want to play I
want to play a part of it for you and so
that we can all enjoy this together take
a listen
I really can't stop baby it's cold
outside I've got
I can call you all right Chris evening
has been so glad
[Applause]
[Music]
with you
[Music]
his name is marina
we're both the dark souls keeping score
I think they should rejoin your body and
your choice
[Music]
[Music]
No then you really are to go though
[Music]
[Applause]
baby
yeah I I love that that that's great I
love it for none of the reasons that
John Legend probably intended because
it's another example of trying to go
woke but going broke and said it's
another example of something getting
woked even though it wasn't broke and
now you end up with a progressive
version of a song that's less
progressive than the version it's trying
to improve so they tried to make it
unsexiest and they ended up with
something that's way more sexist than
what was originally there because now
rather than the man pursuing the woman
and the woman playing hard to get and
dropping hints and everything which is
what the original song is now because
they didn't change the woman's lines in
the song right it sounds like isn't it I
don't think the lines changed at all so
she's still still saying the same things
it's the same lines so now you've got
the woman dropping hints saying that she
wants to stay but you know she couldn't
stay she kind of wants to say while the
fed-up man is trying to kick her butt
out so the whole song is the woman
saying gee I really shouldn't stay but
you know maybe and the man going there
no no you should definitely leave
definitely just a note seriously go just
go are you sure because I mean I
shouldn't stay but no yeah I'm
definitely sure please just plead guy I
mean I've already called your new bird
just please get the hell out meanwhile
it calls her an uber and and the uber
driver Marie poor guy is outside
freezing his butt off waiting while this
chatty woman keeps going on and on and
on about all the reasons she can't stay
but she really wants to so there's there
are a few ways to interpret this and
none of them are particularly
progressive one is that the girl is a
mistress and the dudes trying to get her
out before his wife comes home and
that's that seems to be the working
theory among most people on the internet
the other is that he's just annoyed with
her and not into it and trying to get
her to leave and the other theory is the
other possibility is maybe he's paranoid
in the meet to arrow and he doesn't want
to express any desire for her because
he's afraid that he'll be accused of
assault and so
none of those I don't think any of that
is what they were going for when they
made this song I tend to think of those
options it's probably the second one
he's not into it she is and now he just
wants this girl to leave my favorite
line you heard at the end there is when
that when the girl says I ought to say
no no no and then the guy goes then you
should really go go go you see what they
done rather than the man pursuing the
girl who's interested now we've got a
girl pursuing the man who is not
interested so now it's like we're
eavesdropping on a super awkward
conversation after a date didn't go well
it went from a love song to an anti love
song and that is completely fantastic
all right before we get to some emails
you know this holiday season do your
friends and family a solid by getting
them a daily wire gift membership it's
them it's the best gift anyone could ask
for and the good news for you from now
till January 1st all insider plus gift
memberships will be 25% off that means
your loved ones will get all the
fantastic purse perks plus the majestic
left is tears tumblr and you're gonna
get all the savings that's 25% off all
insider plus membership is this holiday
season go to daily wire.com slash gift
to get your 25% off again that's daily
wire.com slash gift to get your 25% off
give them a gift they'll thank you for
all year long 25% off when you're buying
a gift you cheapskate couldn't even pay
full price could you but no seriously go
go take advantage of that right now
emails Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
Walsh show at gmail.com this is from
Kevin says Matt the porn podcast is the
first podcast I've ever even slightly
disagreed with you on I absolutely agree
it should be regulated but banned I
disagree with maybe that's a bit
libertarian of me as a self-described
conservative but here are a few things
in society that we regulate but have no
positive good to society and could
potentially be banned based on this same
reasoning number one probably the most
directly applicable violent video games
you did a podcast on this yourself not
long ago
should they be outright banned or should
we have better restrictions on them
number two
cigarette / cigars there's no positive
in my opinion they're harmful to the
user as well as non users in the
vicinity now you could make the argument
that like alcohol nicotine has a calming
relaxing effect on the user but many
porn reviewers could make the same claim
about masturbation you can make the
argument that nicotine has certain side
effects that help with anxiety and
attentiveness
but the porn defenders could also make
the argument that masturbation is good
for prostate health I don't mean to
offer to come off like I'm defending
porn again I absolutely agree that we
should be far more strict about
regulating it
I think we're reaching an era with the
Internet where users and more
importantly parents have far better
controls over what they and their kids
can and cannot access or be unwillingly
exposed to the Internet blindsided the
boomer generation with no idea what
content was available how available it
was how to control it what effect it
might have on their children today we
have controls at our fingertips and I
think I hope I pray parents will use the
tools at their disposal to shield their
kids from pornography and violent video
games and cigarettes and drugs now
alcohol but ultimately I think it's up
to the family and it's up to the family
not the government to raise our children
okay Kevin first of all the point you
make about our parent you know as a
millennial I'm the same age as you so
our parents generation blindsided by the
internet I think it's very true a very
unique not unprecedented but very unique
time in history when this new technology
exploded onto the scene and nobody
except for people who are working in the
industry and you know knew all about
this most of the people in society
didn't see it coming and and so parents
were scrambling in real time trying to
figure out how to deal with this new
thing that's taken over the world and it
really was I mean I can remember I I
still remember the first time I ever
encountered the internet and I was in I
don't know I was in elementary school I
remember wait I may be third or fourth
grade and I was at a friend's house and
he had a computer I didn't have a
computer at the time I knew it was at
least I knew what computer was didn't
know what what did what the internet was
and I guess he had a AOL 1.0 and that
was when the entire Internet was
contained
you remember AOL I think we Smythe a AOL
was 3.0 when we finally got it at our
house but even then is the entire
internet is contained on this one home
screen and remember you could go you
could click here for sports if you want
news then there's a kids section where
you go play games or whatever or
whatever you did there to remember and
that's what the internet was and then
within just a few years it it became
this massive other universe that was
slowly encroaching on and devouring our
universe and whereas now it's the two
are indistinguishable so that's kind of
neither here nor there but I think
you're right in the the situation that
our that our parents generation faced
and at least we're a little bit more
prepared for it but as for your
arguments I think we can always get into
the what about this what about that game
so even if you're right about that these
other things you mentioned are similar
in their corrupting influence I don't
see how that in itself is an argument
against banning porn and as for the
things you mentioned I think both of
them alcohol to like someone said
yesterday and as you mentioned those
things are not intrinsically disordered
the way that pornography is they are not
perverse they do not corrupt
psychologically and emotionally the way
pornography does they are not in affront
to the dignity of the participants and
the viewers in the same way and on and
on I just I think they're not the same I
think that they're not even really
similar video games I think most video
games in moderation are fine
some of them do go overboard on the
violence certainly I'm not a fan of that
but again I don't think it's the same as
pornography and that stuff is already
regulated there has to be ratings and
everything and it's the way it's
supposed to work is you can't be you're
not supposed to be able to be a
twelve-year-old shouldn't be able to go
to the store and buy a video game that
has the M label on it so it's not
exactly the same tobacco well here I'm
so again we had we have something that
is very heavily regulated and those
regulations have succeeded in preventing
most kids from smoking cigarettes and
certainly cigars this is a good example
actually because we talk about politics
is downstream from culture and I agree I
say that all the time I think it's true
but politics can also influence the
culture and as conservatives I think we
get so hyper focused on how change the
culture you change politics meanwhile
we're not changing the culture we're
failing utterly in that regard so we're
not changing anything we're saying oh
there's no point in trying to change
things through government won't work
anyway let's focus on the culture okay
well when are we gonna get around to
doing that because we're not doing that
either we're just changing nothing while
the entire culture moves on without us
but it's also a mistake because yeah you
don't want to focus you don't want to
see government as the ultimate end here
the ultimate goal and it is true that
that culture is ultimately what
determines things but laws and politics
and government they can have an
influence on culture I think that the
cigarettes is a great example of this
our parents generation right when when
they were kids everybody smoked
cigarettes and they was it was cool it
was the coolest thing to do and then you
have all these laws and regulations and
all these campaigns and PSAs and trying
to focus on getting kids to stop smoking
cigarettes cigarettes aren't cool
they'll kill you they're bad for you and
it took some time but it actually worked
and if you look at the numbers now that
people still smoke cigarettes but the
vast majority of cigarette smokers are
older they're the people who who in
previous generations had started smoking
most kids aren't smoking cigarettes so
it does have an effect now as I've said
before though you're probably not ever
gonna stop kids from smoking something
so now yeah they don't smoke cigarettes
but there are a lot more people smoking
weed now I think and vaping certainly is
very popular as well but I'm not
convinced with vaping I'm not convinced
that that's the same kind of serious
health drawback
that you know cigarettes have I don't
think there's enough literature to
demonstrate it but again tobacco in and
of itself is not an evil thing it's not
perverse and corrupt corrupting and
degrading in the same way it's just not
the same it can be very dangerous
obviously but with tobacco alcohol sugar
fast food chocolate videogames all of
those things we're talking about things
that are basically harmless in
moderation even tobacco I smoke a cigar
like once a month right and I can't sit
here and say it's never gonna have a
health drawback but I'll probably be
fine it's just it's not enough volume to
do much damage and you know same with
with having fast food it's probably
better if you never eat at McDonald's
it's not like it's healthy to eating
McDowell's but if you have McDonald's
once every few weeks you'll probably be
okay
it's unless you develop some other
health problem some digestive issue
where that's going to exacerbate it then
that's different but for a normal
healthy person at McDonald's everyone
some well it's not a big deal so I think
these are things that are basically
harmless in moderation they're not
intrinsically disordered or corrupting
or evil and they don't have any kind of
traumatic effect on kids just by being
exposed to them so a kid has a Happy
Meal one time it's not gonna ruin his
life it's not gonna affect him
emotionally and psychologically you know
he could even has a cigarette one time
it's it's not going to have that effect
I think that pornography is different
just by its nature and so that's going
to continue and I've got gotten this
argument from people many times what
about this what about that why aren't we
banning this so I just and my response
is always going to be I don't think
those things are the same I think that
pornography is a different kind of thing
from Thomas says hi Matt there's been a
lot of talk of a new civil war my
question for you is twofold do you think
that that's where we are headed and what
is your take on the first civil war was
it really fought over slavery or is that
an oversimplification
Thomas as to your first question no I
don't think we're gonna fight any kind
of civil war in this country anytime
soon keep in mind a civil war is is well
a war it involves two sides two armies
meeting on the battlefield so I don't
see that happening
we don't have millions of people
amassing into armies on either side and
getting ready getting ready for
coordinated campaigns against each other
that's not happening where we are headed
I think is civil unrest not civil war
but civil unrest so I could see a
situation like what we saw in Ferguson
and Baltimore the stuff the antifa is
doing I could see something where that
becomes much more common widespread more
violent more devastating has a larger
impact I could see that happening in
fact I sort of think it's inevitable
that we are headed there unless there's
some massive miraculous sudden cultural
shift I think that's where we're headed
but not to actual war I don't think now
as for the actual civil war the first
civil war as you call it yeah it would
be an oversimplification to say that it
was fought over slavery in my view I
would also it would also be an
oversimplification to say that it wasn't
fought over slavery so either either
thing is an oversimplification there's
no question that one of the primary
motivations of the southern states in
seceding especially the first batch of
seceding states so South Carolina
Mississippi Florida Alabama Georgia
Louisiana Texas there's no question
especially for them that slavery was a
primary concern now for the later States
Virginia Tennessee North Carolina I
think it's a little bit more complicated
but all of the states issued articles of
secession and four of the early states
Texas Mississippi Georgia with South
Carolina they issued something called
documents called decorate a declaration
of causes and these four documents all
that's a declaration of causes that
they're telling us what caused them to
make this split and all of them
prominently cite slavery as a reason it
caused so there's no getting around it
the people
that was all states rights was nothing
to do with slavery I mean you can't
claim that because we have primary
sources of these states saying yeah
slavery is a reason not the only reason
but a big reason so you do have that I
think there's this reaction you've got
this oversimplification that happens
especially in the school system what it
was all about slavery and all the
Confederates are a bunch of evil
scumbags so there's a reaction to that
where we oversimplify on the other side
and say no slavery to have anything to
do with it whatsoever these were I don't
know no we can't do that it and this
it's if you do any kind of research into
the history of it you can't escape the
fact that slavery was all over this
conflict it was definitely a an issue a
big one now does does that make it a
simple slavery caused it sort of thing
can we just say the war was over slavery
no absolutely not for one thing there
were other causes cited by these states
and the other states that joined as well
they were upset about political things
they were upset that Lincoln was elected
they were upset about they were
concerned with states rights they were
they were there were issues related to
tariffs and taxes the economy more
broadly speaking culture I think
essentially these to this North and the
South had already turned into two
different countries basically in their
culture and so these were two sides
looking at each other and they just felt
like they had nothing in common
culturally and no interest in sticking
together for that reason also we have to
distinguish between the causes of
secession and the causes of the war
which aren't necessarily the same early
in the war right up until in the
aftermath of Antietam which was so right
right the Antietam was fought in I think
September of 1862 so up until that point
the war was most certainly most
emphatically
not about slavery Lincoln made it clear
that he was fighting to preserve the
Union not to free the slaves he was very
explicit about this and in the south
leaders like robert e lee they were very
clear to their motivation in fighting
was to defend their homes
famously robert e lee was asked by the
north at the start of the war to lead
the northern army and he considered it
but he declined and his reason was not
oh no i've got to defend our right to
own people
no his reason was this is my home
Virginia of my home you're gonna be
marching an army into Virginia I I can't
lead that army against my own home
against my own family my own sons I
can't do that
we have to understand culturally this
again is the cultural difference in
those days especially in the south when
people talked about their country they
meant their stinked that's just how
people saw it and I would argue that
that is how it was originally intended
to be where people identified first and
foremost with their state in their local
community not with the federal
government or with the overall
conglomeration of states I think that's
that's certainly how the south saw it I
don't think they were wrong for seeing
it that way
okay so so you have the leaders on both
sides the military leaders and even the
political leaders at least on the north
in the beginning certainly we're not
fighting over slavery in their minds
that's not what not why they were
fighting I don't think any denying that
and then you look at the infantry the
men on the field the men that would did
the bleeding and the dying the massed
vast majority of them had no notion that
they were fighting over slavery the
southern boys considered themselves to
be fighting to protect their homes the
northern boys were fighting they thought
you know a gang of traders who were
trying to destroy the Union and that's
the way they looked at it and this is
what makes the question complicated that
really by my reading of it it seems to
me that the men on both sides for the
most part were noble brave considered
themselves to be fighting for a noble
cause and in both cases a noble cause
that had nothing to do with slavery but
that changed after Antietam and then
Lincoln noticed that the public's faith
in the war was starting to wane he was
worried about Europe getting involved
and taking to fight alongside the south
which was a very real possibility and so
he issued the Emancipation Proclamation
I think most people know did not free a
single slave and was specifically
written so that it would not free a
single slave and it stipulates in the
document that because at that time the
North did control States slave holding
States and those states are exempted so
basically this the document says the the
slaves that the federal government has
the power to free right now are not
freed it's only the slaves that we have
no power over at the moment that are
freed so it was it was a political
document but a genius one and the idea
was to reframe the narrative of the war
not actually to free the slaves Lincoln
really was not the great Emancipator his
but his his his goal here was to
preserve the Union and so by changing
the narrative making it about slavery
now Europe's not going to get involved
on the side of the south it's gonna
change the perception of the war and and
I think that's that's what it did and
probably from that point on at least
among the leaders in the north it's they
started to think okay we're fighting to
free the slaves but in the south I don't
think there was ever a point where most
of the generals or most of the men doing
the fighting ever consider themselves to
be fighting to keep slaves especially
considering almost none of them had
slaves among the infantry I mean these
were poor farm boys didn't even have
shoes a lot of them they certainly
didn't own slaves and so they're not
they're not gonna go out and die for the
sake of some rich plantation owners
right to own slaves that's not what they
considered it to be and even on the
North I mean grants grants own wife own
slaves so do you think that he felt so
strongly about the issue that he was
charging in the battle to kill people
for owning slaves when his own family
owned slaves
no so it's look it's a it is a comp it's
it's a fascinating period of history
it's an important period of history for
us to read about and understand
especially given where we are right now
in our culture but just like with so
many human conflicts whether we're
talking about conflicts on a large scale
between countries or conflicts between
individuals it's it's never it's rare
as simple as people try to make it out
to be and there is rarely a a clear good
guy bad guy sometimes there is obviously
but I think in most cases there isn't
and you just you have to be willing to
look at it from a more nuanced
perspective and you have to be willing
to accept that in that a the answer to a
question like what caused this is not
you you're not going to be able to
answer it in one sentence and you're
certainly not gonna be able to answer it
with one word like slavery okay so that
was that was it that was my history
lecture for the day thanks for bringing
that bring that up though interesting
topic and I think we'll leave it there
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed
the Matt Walsh show is produced by Sean
Hampton executive producer Jeremy boring
senior producer Jonathan hey supervising
producer Mathis Glover supervising
producer Robert Stirling technical
producer Austin Stephens editor Donovan
Fowler audio mixer Mike Cora Mina the
Matt Walsh show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 19
Justice Department inspector general
Michael Horowitz testified before the
Senate on his report and it turns out
that the mainstream media have been
lying to us about everything on the same
day the media led by the New York Times
reported that President Trump was
redefining Judaism as a nationality
sparking widespread hysteria before it
turned out that report was also
completely false and then as the cherry
on top of the fake news Sunday CNN's Don
Lemon has a meltdown on air over a meme
we will examine how and why the fake
news lie so well check it out on the
Michael Noel's show
[Music]